[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und bettina schausten
guten abend olaf scholz hat sich erklärt
zum zweiten mal in dieser woche hat der
bundeskanzler seinen kurs in sachen
waffenlieferung an die ukraine
verteidigt prinzip seines handelns sein
sagte er dem spiegel zu verhindern dass
die nato kriegs partei werde und
wörtlich es darf keinen atomkrieg gehen
ob der allerdings die unmittelbare folge
wäre würde deutschland panzer an die
ukraine liefern dies scholz
unbeantwortet nach dem wunsch der union
soll nun nächste woche im bundestag
namentlich abgestimmt werden über
schwere waffen aus brodbeck berichtet
und beginnt mit der außenministerin die
zum abschluss ihrer reise ins baltikum
auch heute wieder zweifel an deutscher
zuverlässigkeit zu zerstreuen suchte
deutsche waffen in litauen sind sie
schon bei der bundeswehr die dort die
grenze zwischen nato und russland
schützt besucht der außenministerin es
geht darum den partnern nicht nur im
baltikum die deutsche politik seit
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine zu erklären
sie berlins unterstützung gegen putins
russland zu versichern
deutschland hat hier eine besondere
verantwortungsvolle rolle bis die
ukraine wieder frei und sicher ist ein
waffenstillstand um jeden preis kann es
nicht geben einen diktat frieden werden
wir nicht akzeptieren
allein die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
entscheiden über ihre zukunft per
interview wird sich heute der kanzler
gegen die kritik die ihm aus der ukraine
die opposition aber auch den eigenen
reihen immer lauter entgegenschlägt
berlins zögern schwere waffen aus
eigenen beständen zu liefern begründete
scholz mit der notwendigkeit das
bündnisgebiet jederzeit verteidigen zu
können das ist eine schwierige abwägung
die wir gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
ständig treffen müssen denn die
bedrohung des nato gebiets durch
russland besteht ja fort und weiter ich
tue alles um eine eskalation zu
verhindern die zu einem dritten
weltkrieg führt es darf keinen atomkrieg
geben unterstützung eine gemeinsame
abgestimmte strategien der jede
europäische partner und wir reden ja
nicht nur europäische partners nach
unserer internationalen partner
insbesondere die usa eine rolle
einnehmen kann und da müssen wir
vertrauenswürdig als deutschland
auftreten dass es gerade unsere aufgabe
ich finde das machen der europäischen im
bundestag hingegen wir nun die union die
bundesregierung mit einem antrag vor
sich hertreiben das parlament solle
beschließen der ukraine schwere waffen
zu liefern
dort gibt es wenn ich es richtig
übersehe eine ziemlich deutliche und
klare mehrheit aus cdu csu fdp und
grünen die das befürworten was wir
wollen nämlich der ukraine mit den
waffen zu helfen die sie braucht um sich
selbst verteidigen zu können was wir
nicht tun sollten ist hier in politisch
parteitaktische spiele zu spielen
parteitaktisch versuchen profit zu
schlagen aus einer brutalen situation
wie sie gerade in der ukraine ist und da
habe ich den appell an die union dass
man das sein lässt jetzt diese
parteitaktischen spieler zu spielen
deutschland und die waffen für die
ukraine der streit darum geht für die
regierung erst richtig los
tja da müssen wir auch heute nachfragen
bei theo koll in berlin was bezweckt die
union mit diesem antrag zur abstimmung
partei- und fraktionschef märz hatte
scholz ja eigentlich unterstützung in
der zeitenwende zugesagt
die union argumentiert wenn die
bundesregierung schon keine schweren
waffen liefert dann müsse das parlament
liefern dort gebe es eine politische
mehrheit für den export schwerer waffen
damit soll der bundestag quasi als
antreiber für die ampel genutzt werden
und zwar mit hilfe der jähnigen bei den
grünen und bei der fdp die unzufrieden
mit der ukraine politik der regierung
sind einerseits gibt es ja ganz
offensichtlich sehr präsenten kritiker
der regierungslinie andererseits aber
wird es darf man nicht vergessen die
ukraine politik der ampel im
bundessicherheitsrat von allen drei
parteiführungen gemeinsam getragen eine
mehrheit für den unionsantrag wäre also
gleichzusetzen mit einer massiven
regierungs und auch koalitionskrise
jetzt hat der bundeskanzler die ganze
woche den unmut mit seiner
zurückhaltenden linie nicht in den griff
bekommen jetzt beim zweiten mal wählte
er ja ein denkbar großes argument die
sorge vor dem atomkrieg kann er damit
jetzt mehr überzeugen also alles das
regierungshandeln in diesem moment
erklärt kann nur besser sein mein
eindruck ist es der ukraine krieg ein
brutales schlaglicht auf das
kommunikative probleme des kanzlers
geworfen hat olaf scholz ist zwar
einerseits ein extrem selbstbewusster
mensch andererseits aber niemand der die
große bühne suchte ist wie eine art
hauptdarsteller der wenig text für seine
rolle braucht er wieder vorn an die
rampe eilt noch große gesten beansprucht
es ist schlicht sein wiesn er ist nicht
wie boris johnson sofort nach kiew
gefahren er hat nicht den medialen raum
gefüllt das wäre aber in einer solchen
krisensituation offensichtlich nötig die
rufe nach führungen sind ja auch
entsprechend immer lauter geworden dazu
kommt dann noch die geheimniskrämerei
überlieferungen das lange zögern die
unterschiedlichen begründungen warum was
alles nicht geht von der heutigen
warnung vor einem atomkrieg kann man
halten was man will aber es ist
zumindest eine wichtige handlungs
erklärung
dankeschön theo koll und in berlin wird
es auch nächste woche wieder spannend
tag 58 im krieg in der ukraine bis zum 9
mai dem tag des sieges über
hitler-deutschland will russlands
präsident putin einen sieg verkünden
können einer seiner generäle benannte
heute noch einmal das ziel
es gehe darum im osten die vollständige
kontrolle über den gesamten osten
des landes zu gewinnen und damit eine
landverbindung zur krim halbinsel zu
schaffen ob das in gut zwei wochen
gelingen kann zweifeln experten an
bisher ist die offensive im osten
offenbar nicht so massiv ausgefallen wie
von der ukraine befürchtet
kurz vor dem orthodoxen osterfest ist
die situation im belagerten mario pohl
weiter dramatisch damit beginnt ralf
panichi sein bericht bilder einer stadt
die eigentlich keiner mehr ist mario
pohl im osten der ukraine aufnahmen aus
dem russisch besetzten teilen der stadt
die auch zeigen sollen dass es erstes
leben gibt inmitten der zerstörungen die
stadt sei aber immer noch nicht
vollständig in russischer hand wie die
ukrainische seite heute erneut betont
der kampf um mario pohl geht weiter es
ist nicht nur ein kampf um das auch
stahlwerk es finden auch
straßenschlachten im stadtzentrum statt
auch panzerschlachten
vor allem um das als auch stahlwerk am
rande der stadt wird gekämpft über die
genaue situation dort herrscht
unklarheit der industriekomplex auch
heute unter beschuss und der versuch
russischer truppen es abzurücken wie zum
beweis posen tschetschenische kämpfer
auf russischer seite in den ruinen
siegessicher doch noch immer harren hier
auch ukrainische zivilisten aus und
ukrainische kämpfer vor allem der
ultranationalen azoff brigaden
natürlich gibt es zivilisten im
stahlwerk aber sie halten sich getrennt
vom militär auf wir wollen sie nicht
gefährden denn die russische propaganda
wird dies ausnutzen um zivile opfer zu
rechtfertigen
20 km entfernt von mario pohl die stadt
manus satellitenbilder von hier zeigen
frisch aufgehäufte erdhügel die
schlimmstes ahnen lassen es sollen 300
grabstellen seien mit platz für
möglicherweise 9000 tote der ukrainische
vorwurf russische truppen hätten hier
menschen aus mario pohl verscharrt die
frontlinie im osten der ukraine selbst
in den kleinsten orten sind die zeichen
des krieges zu sehen und zu hören
selbst vor dem orthodoxen osterfest
keine zeichen von waffenpause die
gespräche zwischen russland und der
ukraine die immer noch stattfinden seien
festgefahren beide seiten geben sich
dafür die schuld
leider lehnt russland den vorschlag ab
den oster waffenstillstand herzustellen
dies zeigt sehr gut wie die führer
dieses staates tatsächlich über den
glauben denken über einen der
wichtigsten feiertage
hoffnung ruht nun auf ein treffen in der
kommenden woche am dienstag reist
un-generalsekretär görisch nach moskau
will kreml-chef putin nun außenminister
lavrov treffen um eine waffenruhe zu
erreichen
engel zu enge verbindungen zu russland
beim bau der nordsee pipeline nord
stream zwei bringen mecklenburg
vorpommerns ministerpräsidentin manuela
schwesig in bedrängnis wir haben diese
woche bereits hier darüber berichtet die
pipeline ist geschichte aber schwer sich
nicht aus der kritik im mittelpunkt die
maßgeblich mit russischem geld
finanzierte klima und umwelt stiftung
des landes die unter anderem den
fertigbau gegen us-sanktionen
sicherstellen sollte schwesig nennt nord
stream zwei inzwischen einen fehler und
sprach sich für die auflösung der
stiftung aus sie bekräftigte zugleich
dass sie im amt bleiben werde heute nun
präsentierte der stiftungsvorstand
schwesigs vorgänger erwin sellering ein
gutachten das besagt eine auflösung sein
stiftungs rechtlich nicht möglich was
die stiftung konkret für die vollendung
der pipeline investiert hat darüber gibt
es kaum infos auch heute nicht ja und da
fragen wir unseren landes
korrespondenten bernd mosebach in
schwerin während sellering galt ja immer
als förderer schwede ist jetzt bringt
dieses votum sie ja zusätzlich in die
bredouille oder
ja das war schon eine überraschung heute
diese kurzfristig angekündigte
pressekonferenz von erwin sellering mit
diesem gutachten eigentlich sollte es ja
vom landtag ein gutachten geben dass in
den nächsten tagen erwartet wird aber
das wollte offenbar erwähnen sie alleine
nicht abwarten und hat ein eigenes
vorgestellt mit einer klaren aussage mit
ihm und auch aus rechtlichen gründen
wird es nie und nimmer eine auflösung
dieser stiftung eben und das ist
natürlich auch ein stück würde einer
frau gegen manuela schwesig weil sie und
auch der komplette landtag ja die
auflösung gefordert haben politisch ist
diese stiftung schon lange tot und außer
erwin sellering unserem team glaubt
wahrscheinlich niemand hier dass sie
überhaupt noch eine zukunft hat aber das
erhöht natürlich auch den druck noch mal
auf manuela schwesig denn es wird
weitergehen es wird diese klimastiftung
weiter als ein top thema hier in
schwerin am köcheln halten und im raum
steht ja nicht mehr nicht weniger als
der verdacht dass gazprom im grunde
regierungshandeln in schwerin
mitbestimmt haben könnte der
cdu-generalsekretär czaja bringt jetzt
staatsanwaltschaftliche ermittlungen ins
spiel aber wie eng wird es tatsächlich
für schwesig die eng könnte es werden
ja das war ein großes thema in dieser
woche nämlich die frage ob in der
gründungsphase gazprom sozusagen das
heft des handelns in der hand hatte und
der ministerpräsidentin und denen die
hier diese stiftung aufgesetzt haben
sozusagen diktiert hat was da drin
stehen soll oder ob es wie die
landesregierung sagt nur anregungen bei
manuela schwesig hat in dieser woche ja
bereits zugestanden dass sie auch
persönlich gespräche mit der note 7
2-führung in dieser sache geführt hat
das sei natürlich dass man auch
gespräche in dieser form führt aber der
politische druck ist natürlich größer
geworden und alle fragen land auf ihrem
tisch weil am ende sie die politisch
hauptverantwortliche ist als
ministerpräsidentin und sie muss viele
dieser fragen natürlich auch beantworten
und in zeiten in dem in diesem
kriegszeiten wo jeder gefragt wird wie
stehst du zu russland und wie standest
du noch vor einem jahr zu russland und
in zeiten in denen ihre partei in
landtagswahlkämpfen steht und in zeiten
wo der spd kanzler auch nicht gerade
leichte zeiten beklebt ist natürlich
noch einmal eine solche geschichte wie
hier die klimastiftung bei manuela
schwesig noch mal im fokus und sie hat
in dieser woche
rücktrittsforderungen abgelehnt aber da
ist noch nicht alles gesprochen es
bleibt spannend hier in schwerin die
einordnung von bernd mosebach vielen
dank nach stellen
in afghanistan reißt die serie von
anschlägen nicht ab nach zwei bomben
hatten taten gestern im norden des
landes mit vielen toten traf es heute
wieder eine moschee in kundus gewalt und
instabilität in afghanistan nehmen zu
damit beginnen die nachrichten mit
grunde lag aus bei dem anschlag heute
sind mindestens 33 menschen getötet
worden mehr als 40 wurden verletzt die
meisten der opfer sind religions-
schüler sie hatten an den
freitagsgebeten teilgenommen die attacke
gestern auf eine schiitische moschee in
masar i scharif reklamierten sunnitische
extremisten für sich terror experten
befürchten wegen der rivalität unter den
extremistengruppen weitere anschläge
auch auf dem tempelberg in jerusalem hat
es wieder zusammenstöße zwischen
palästinensischen demonstranten und
israelischen polizisten gegeben vor der
al aksa moschee setzten sie
blendgranaten gummigeschosse und
tränengas ein zuvor waren die polizisten
von demonstranten mit steinen attackiert
worden fast 60 menschen wurden verletzt
die moschee gilt als drittwichtigstes
heiligtum im islam die klagemauer am
tempelberg ist für juden der heiligste
ort
in sachsen ist innenminister wöller nach
anhaltender kritik entlassen worden
ministerpräsident kretschmann sagte es
sei ein personeller neuanfang nötig
villa war unter anderem
vetternwirtschaft bei
personalentscheidungen vorgeworfen
worden der cdu politiker war auch in die
schlagzeilen geraten durch skandale bei
einer polizeieinheit die illegale
schießübungen veranstaltet und einen
skiurlaub als fortbildung deklariert
hatte nachfolger soll armin schuster
werden bisher präsident des bundesamtes
für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe
das berliner landgericht hat den
parteiausschluss des früheren
brandenburger fdp vorsitzenden andreas
kalbitz bestätigt eine klage des
brandenburger landtags abgeordneten
wurde abgewiesen laut urteil hatte
kalbitz die afg arg listig getäuscht als
er 2013 eintrat der rechtsaußen
politiker hatte vorherige
mitgliedschaften bei der mittlerweile
verbotenen rechtsextremen heimattreuen
deutschen jugend sowie bei den
republikanern verschwiegen die
kostenlosen corona schnelltests stehen
wieder in der diskussion
der vorstand der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung gassen hat ein ende
der sogenannten bürger tests gefordert
in der ärztezeitung setzt er sich
dagegen für die förderung der
verlässlicheren pcr tests ein kritik an
gassen forderung kommt von der stiftung
patientenschutz das rp meldete 161
1718 neuinfektionen knapp 5000 fälle
mehr als vor einer woche
289 menschen starben mit dem virus die
sieben tage incidents steigt leicht auf
wahlkampfabschluss in frankreich vor der
entscheidenden stichwahl um das
präsidentenamt am sonntag haben
amtsinhaber emanuel makro und seine
rechtspopulistische herausforderin
marine le pen heute zum letzten mal
versucht für die wahl zu mobilisieren
vor allem bei den unentschlossenen
das rennen ist offen auch wenn man/frau
seinen vorsprung in den umfragen in den
letzten tagen ausbauen konnte aber das
schreckgespenst einer europafeindlichen
rechtsextreme nationalisten in élysées
ist nicht gebannt an arendt aus paris
auf sie kommt es an wähler die sich
weder von einem wirtschaftsliberalen
emanuel makro noch von einer
rechtsnationalen marine le pen vertreten
fühlen die sich einen präsidenten aus
dem linken lager gewünscht hätten da
sind ins an danny nördliche vorstadt von
paris mehr als 60 prozent bally bagayoko
ist einer von ihnen er hadert fühlt sich
in die ecke gedrängt auf
keinen fall will ich marine le pen
helfen an die macht zu kommen deshalb
habe ich nun zwei möglichkeiten entweder
ich stimme für den amtierenden
präsidenten den ich eigentlich ablehnen
oder ich enthalte mich
und so will genau hier makor nun auf den
letzten metern visieren an diesem ort wo
arbeitslosigkeit und armut hoch sind
gilt er als präsident der reichen
länder nie in wut rufen sie
die frage ist wohin sie diese wut am
sonntag treiben wird
wir haben den eindruck dass wir die wahl
haben zwischen pest und cholera
maicon versucht zu überzeugen indem er
sich von der band klar abgrenzt vor
einem rechtsruck warnt
wir dürfen uns nicht an den aufstieg
extrem rechter ideen gewöhnen es gibt
unterschiede innerhalb von
demokratischen debatten die sich in
lokalen oder landesweiten wahlen
ausdrücken können aber daneben gibt es
auch grundsätzliche unterschiede in den
werten
werte die nicht nur den künftigen weg
frankreichs sondern auch europas
bestimmen marine le pen will raus aus
den zwängen der eu wie sie es nennt will
die zusammenarbeit mit deutschland
beenden sie warnt vor dem niedergang der
französischen nation inszeniert sich als
deren retterin
lektor volk frankreichs steht auf gegen
jene die so wenig achtung für die
verteidigung unserer zivilisation haben
die deine geschichte in den dreck ziehen
eine kultur deine traditionen die deine
demografische zukunft der immigration
unterwerfen
worte wie le pen and sell any unwählbar
machen dürften hier wie in vielen teilen
des landes drängen andere probleme
steigende lebensmittel- und
energiepreise wohnungs und topmodel
wir haben angst vor marie le pen und
marco weiss genau dass viele von uns
deshalb gegen sie und für ihn stimmen
werden obwohl wir seiner liberalen
politik nicht zustimmen gleich nach der
wahl werden wir daher auf die straße
gehen und protestieren darin letzte
umfragen sehen mag und zwar im vorsprung
doch selbst bei einem wahlsieg am
sonntag müsste er wohl weiter kämpfen
zugeständnisse machen und versuchen das
land zu einem
ja im heute-journal update später mehr
zur ausgangslage vor der wahl und zu den
konsequenzen und am sonntag dann an
dieser stelle der ganze wahlabend mit
ergebnissen und reaktionen
die krone krise hat ein neues nachdenken
über globale kreisläufe und
wirtschaftliche abhängigkeiten ausgelöst
besser erzwungen lieferketten wurden
gekappt die frage der produktion vor ort
wird drängender so sollen halbleiter nun
auch verstärkt in europa hergestellt
werden der ukraine krieg verstärkt den
trend die sorge vor energieknappheit
setzt industrie und politik unter
zugzwang und überall dort wo eine
möglichst autarke energiegewinnung
gewährleistet werden kann siedeln sich
unternehmen gerne an so kam ein big
player wie tesla auf brandenburg
florian kojak zeigt uns diese
entwicklung in ostdeutschland erster
halt altenburg in thüringen
spatenstich in der skatstadt die neue
produktionshalle der spielkartenfabrik
altenburg soll schon bis jahresende
stehen hier am traditionsstandort wo sie
seit 190 jahren spielkarten herstellen
das geplante werk
17.500 quadratmeter groß mit einem
möglichst kleinen ökologischen
fußabdruck dafür sorgen sollen e
ladestationen toiletten die mit
regenwasser spülen und eine große
photovoltaik anlage auf dem dach
geschafft uns in etwa eine 30-prozentige
autarkie in sachen der stromversorgung
die fließt ganz klar in die ganzen
anlagen techniken die wir haben das
heißt die ganze lüftungs und
beschichtungsanlagen und natürlich auch
in den maschinenpark hundert kilometer
weiter westlich in thüringen sind sie
schon einen schritt weiter c rtl baut
hier am erfurter kreuz die größte
batteriezellen fabrik europas 1,8
milliarden euro will der chinesische
konzern investieren 2000 arbeitsplätze
sollen entstehen ein investment mit
sogwirkung für die ganze region
rundherum siedeln sich bereits forschung
und zulieferer an wenn wir europa als
ganzes nehmen haben wir eine ideale lage
wir haben eine ganze reihe von anfragen
von firmen die im moment aus der ganzen
globalen produktion in die jeweiligen
märkte gehen wollen das heißt das was
man in europa kauft will man in zukunft
auch in europa produzieren und besonders
gut gerade der osten deutschlands auch
weil dort so große flächen überhaupt
verfügbar sind die fand tesla in
grünheide und zuletzt auch intel bei
magdeburg dort will der chip-hersteller
aus diesem acker das zentrum der
halbleiter industrie europas machen eu
und bund fördern mit milliarden das und
das öko potenzial in der region hat
intel hierher gelockt
für den standort
wir haben uns auf die fahnen geschrieben
und als ziel vorgenommen bereits vom
ersten tag an die fabriken zu 100
prozent mit grünstrom zu betreiben in
deutschland kommt aktuell etwa die
hälfte des stroms aus erneuerbaren
energien noch zu wenig sagen fachleute
wichtig ist dass für den ökostrom
schnell weiter ausbauen das senkt er die
energiekosten massiv aber stärkt auch
das image aber auch die infrastruktur
muss stimmen und da gibt es noch einiges
nachzuholen
fortschritte bei der energiewende werden
immer stärker zum standort und image
faktor für unternehmen oder wie sie in
der skatstadt altenburg sagen würden
ökostrom ist trumpf
so und jetzt nochmal nachrichten gundula
gause
in mecklenburg vorpommern sind die
korona hotspot regelungen aufgehoben
worden das oberverwaltungsgericht des
landes hat sie auf antrag der afg
landtagsfraktion gekippt laut urteil
hätte der landtag für einzelne gebiete
konkrete maßnahmen beschließen müssen
und nicht für das ganze land in münchen
hat das erste größere volksfest seit
beginn der pandemie begonnen ein
testlauf für das oktoberfest das wegen
corona zweimal abgesagt worden war
der andauernde corona lockdown in
shanghai hat dort zu einem stau von
frachtschiffen vor dem hafen geführt
shanghai gehört zu den weltgrößten
umschlagplätzen folglich sind die folgen
des staus dort weltweit zu spüren frank
bethmann früher oder später also auch
hier in deutschland ja die reedereien
versuchen derzeit alles um die
ladungsmengen zügig zu transportieren
aber der hafen selbst ist noch nicht mal
das größte problem wegen der strengen co
oder maßnahmen kommen kaum nach lkws mit
containern zum hafen viele unternehmen
bekämen ihre waren teilweise seit mehr
als drei wochen nicht mehr aus dem land
sagt maximilian boutique der delegierte
der deutschen wirtschaft in shanghai
weiter die verknappung des angebots an
lieferungen aus china wird die bereits
jetzt schon hohe inflation in
deutschland weiter negativ beeinflussen
der druck auf die preise hierzulande
wird also nicht ab sondern wohl eher
noch weiter zunehmen auch weil die
maritimen lieferketten bereits vor dem
lock down an shanghai kräftig in
unordnung geraten waren und sich der
schiffsverkehr bis heute nicht
normalisiert hat weltweit nicht nur für
asiens küsten sondern auch vor hamburg
oder wie hier vor los angeles sollen
etwa 1800 der rund 9000 containerschiffe
festhing der stau auf den meeren bedroht
erneut die weltwirtschaft die
aktienmärkte aber die suchten sich heute
einen anderen buhmann jerome paul
nachdem der us notenbankchef bereits am
gestrigen andeutete dass in den usa die
zinsen schon im mai deutlich angehoben
werden könnten gegen die aktienmärkte
auf tauchstation
auch der dax der heute zweieinhalb
prozent verloren dann hoffen auf die
nächste woche und sagen danke nach
frankfurt in der fußball-bundesliga hat
der 31 spieltag begonnen mit der partie
vfl wolfsburg gegen mainz 05
gerade eben ging das spiel zu ende mit
einem klaren 5 0 sieg der wolfsburger
gegen die mainzer die auch noch eine
rote karte kassiert haben
so freitagabend saß ist heute show zeit
damit geht es gleich nach dem wetter
weiter und um 0.20 meldet sich nah sein
möchte mir mit unserem heute-journal
updates morgen begrüßen sie an dieser
stelle christian sievers und hanna
zimmermann tschüss und ein schönes
wochenende
[Musik]
guten abend auch am wochenende hält das
hoch über skandinavien durch die tiefs
von süden und von südwesten kommen uns
aber näher und deswegen wird das wetter
zumindest in süddeutschland
wechselhafter das merken wir schon heute
nacht wenn zwischen sachsen und bayern
ist doch häufiger stark bewölkt bis
bedeckt bleibt und es auch hier und da
etwas regnen kann im norden klart es
dagegen richtig auf und so sinken die
temperaturen rund um berlin auf 3 bis 2
grad hier droht also noch einmal
bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
nacht im westen mit tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 9 und 7 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen auf
rügen bei elf grad sonst werden 14 bis
20 grad erreicht und am mildesten wird
es entlang des reichs in norddeutschland
gibt es morgen strahlenden sonnenschein
und einen klaren himmel nur wenige
kleine quellwolken stört der wind dazu
kommt aus westlichen richtungen
in süddeutschland dagegen verdichten
sich die wolken mehr und mehr und am
nachmittag kann es dann im südwesten und
auch aus den alpen heraus einige
vielleicht auch mal kräftigere
regenschauer und gewitter geben regen
und gewitter breiten sich dann im laufe
des sonntags weiter nordwärts aus
erreichen sachsen thüringen hessen
rheinland pfalz und das saarland in
norddeutschland bleibt es dagegen
freundlich die höchsttemperaturen am
sonntag liegen zwischen 9 und 17 grad
und ähnlich startet dann auch die neue
woche am mittwoch aber ist es dann für
uns alle wohl stunden der trocken guten
abend